horas después de atacar diversas
ciudades ucranianas a lo largo y ancho
de todo el país en calles en parques y
en plazas el presidente ruso ha vuelto a
amenazar a los ucranianos acusado a kiev
de estar detrás de lo que él considera
ataques terroristas contra el puente de
crimea este fin de semana y avisado de
que si se vuelven a producir la
respuesta de Rusia será dura y
contundente el presidente ruso ha dicho
que está muy claro que detrás de estos
ataques están precisamente los servicios
de seguridad ucranianos y por eso ha
dicho que los ataques a partir de ahora
de Rusia tendrán la escala
correspondiente a la amenaza que se está
creando contra la federación rusa desde
Ucrania en territorio ucraniano el
recuento de víctimas ya supera las 10
personas muertas por estos ataques
Aunque Vladimir Putin asegura que se
trataba de ataques con misiles de
precisión contra infraestructuras de
transporte y también militares en
Ucrania